guys tonight The Bachelorette used the  musical hit don't cry for me Argentina  to really make the episode work so so  I'm in a very musical mood and I'm gonna  spend my drive home from work singing  just about every major musical number i  know and making it about chad johnson  the infamous Bachelorette villain who  was sadly missing from tonight's show  but he will not be missing from this one  will start big I dreamed a dream of Chad  Johnson in sleep the guards watched me  in dreams i slayed my fellow contestants  who dared speak my name to Jojo so bang  every door for me hide all my weights  from me take all my steroids and let me  withdraw I don't need to be popular  don't care about being popular how do  you measure measure a year in punches in  jabs assaults in threats of life how  about love I just wants to be loved  ah